should you play the elder scrolls for
oblivion in 2021
the short answer is an unequivocal
definitive and
exuberant yes partly because who the
[ __ ] knows when elder scrolls vi
will finally come out and partly because
oblivion is
excellent in its own awkward middle
child sort of way
[Music]
you don't have to look far to find
oblivion's blemishes but if you can look
past them there's an imaginative
ambitious fantasy adventure that in many
ways bethesda hasn't been able to
replicate
since also the voice acting is
impeccable
i'm talking amazing stop you violated
the law
pay the quarter fine or serve your
sentence your stolen goods are now
forfeit before we get going make sure to
subscribe
we love making videos like this and your
support means the world
it sounds strange to call oblivion the
awkward middle child since it is the
fourth mainline game in the series
so let's back up a bit to find out why
it was such a huge jump from earlier
elder scrolls games the elder scrolls
has been around since 1994. however it
didn't stake its claim in the console
space until 2002 with the elder scrolls
3 morrow end morrowind had a lot of
firsts for the series most notably it
was the first
fully 3d mainline elder scrolls game
technically
redguard was the first 3d elder scrolls
but yeah
his soul is in the sword morrowind laid
the groundwork for every single
subsequent bethesda rpg
rather than creating a sprawling open
world todd howard yes i was in the chess
club and the gang opted to create a
smaller more focused world that still
gave
players an immense amount of freedom so
yes morrowind
was kind of a big deal now if you've
played any modern bethesda rpg you're
probably thinking that all of them have
massive sprawling open worlds but let me
put this in context
morrowind had a world space of roughly
16 kilometers
the elder scrolls 2 daggerfall had an
incomprehensible world space of a
hundred and sixty one thousand
kilometers
or something like that bethesda claimed
it was about the size of great britain
granted a majority of it was
procedurally generated
morrowind's smaller size allowed
bethesda to create a richer rpg
experience with
a more consistent and meaningful design
that thoughtfully rewarded exploration
morrowind wasn't perfect though the
combat needed work the towns felt a bit
lifeless and some aspects were
needlessly complicated
four years later in 2006 bethesda
followed it up with the elder scrolls iv
oblivion for xbox 360 and pc
it came to ps3 a year later on paper
oblivion addresses many of the issues
people had with morrowind
it had a more focused plot the ai was
much more dynamic the combat was more
balanced and approachable and it looked
a hell of a lot better
however many of those improvements came
with their own downsides
sure the ai was more dynamic but it was
far from perfect
it also didn't help that every
character's first line was their name
and what they do
like without fail welcome to colovian
traders
skingrad's finest selection of general
merchandise
i'm gunder just let me know what you
want thank you for freeing me
i'm gromman gramaron the bloated floats
bouncer and helmsman
i've been locked in that storage room
for hours in theory
the combat should have been more
balanced because enemies leveled up with
the player no matter where you were in
the world but this
ended up robbing the player of a sense
of growth and although the game
looked better than morrowind the setting
was a bit dull
oblivion leaned heavily into its
classical high fantasy
aesthetic with stone castles green
fields and knights in shining armor
everything just felt a little too
familiar there was no edge
at least on the surface finally in 2011
we got the elder scrolls 5 skyrim
assuming you've played skyrim and given
that it's on every platform under the
sun
you probably have then you know that a
lot of the issues folks had with
oblivion were addressed the npcs behaved
more realistically
enemy difficulty varied giving your
character a stronger sense of
progression and the world had a lot more
flavor to it from a zoomed out
perspective
it's easy to see why oblivion was either
forgotten or ignored by fans
it didn't invent the wheel like
morrowind and it didn't perfect it like
skyrim some might even say that oblivion
was a stepping stone for skyrim's
unparalleled success
i wouldn't be surprised if most people
think of oblivion as that game with all
the funny faces and to some degree
they aren't wrong the faces are
something else entirely
we don't like strangers poking their
noses
into our business so then why is it
worth revisiting the elder scrolls 4
oblivion
15 years later when you can just play
skyrim hell if you wait long enough you
can just play sky oblivion which aims to
bring oblivion to skyrim's engine
if that's something that sounds cool to
you be sure to check out my video on
skype livian after this
but i think there's a sadistic charm
both intentional and
unintentional that's unique to oblivion
there's an odd duality to it all
on one hand you have this colorful rpg
with happy looking elves and cat people
and then you travel to hell to stop a
satanic cult trying to eradicate the
mortal plane
it's difficult to pinpoint but this
feeling radiates from everything you see
and permeates into everything you do
this undercroft is well quite cursed
any desecration will cause my ancestors
to rise from their graves
and defend their resting place i can
hear them coming as we speak
you must protect me escort me to the
grey mare where i can buy passage out of
coral
[Music]
let's start at the very beginning unless
you've got a list of mods installed the
character crater is
all sorts of deranged if you think it's
hard to make a good looking character in
dark souls you've never played oblivion
after you've created your absolute mad
light of a character you are berated by
a racist dark elf in the cell opposite
to you
oh look an imperial in the imperial
prison
i guess they don't play favorites huh
your own kinsmen think you're a piece of
human
trash even if you pick a dark elf too
this ass clown will still
find some way to insult you fortunately
the dark brotherhood lets you exact your
revenge
on this idiot later in the story the
nightmare
no no gods gods help me
somebody help assassin after that you're
greeted by sir patrick stewart aka
emperor uriel septim vii
who doesn't call for your immediate
execution because he saw you in a dream
let me see your face you are the one
from my dreams
yes the thing that kicks off your entire
adventure is sir patrick stewart's dream
there are lore reasons for this but
whatever you aren't the chosen one
you don't have dragon blood flowing
through your veins and you don't have
any emotional ties to the main story
your ugly ass character is about as
special as he looks
you can quite literally take patrick
stewart's words of warning as the
ramblings of an old man approaching his
death and do whatever the hell you want
and that's precisely what i do
every time i start a new game now
technically you can do this in skyrim
too but you can't really avoid your fate
of being the dragonborn and savior of
skyrim oblivion just puts you in the
shoes of a normal ass person who gets
pardoned by the emperor because of a
dream i know i said that already but i
just can't get over the fact that
patrick stewart's dream is what kicks
off your entire adventure
even if you decide to follow the main
story which let's be honest you probably
won't because it's the elder scrolls
we're talking about here but
if you do you quickly realize that the
story really isn't about you
sure you play a huge role in it closing
oblivion gates and the like but the
story is really about martin's septum
aka sean bean the true heir to the
throne accepting his fate and saving the
world
he even has a classic heroes journey arc
that runs parallel to your story
you need a priest i don't think i'll be
much help to you
i'm having trouble understanding the
gods right now
if all this is part of a divine plan
i'm not sure i want to have anything to
do with it you are more or less a
glorified aaron boy for his royal
highness
i get why skyrim didn't revisit this
theme the world is created for the
player after all and the player should
feel
important in that world especially as
they kill more dragons and complete more
quests
however because of this i've found role
playing a character much more
interesting and
oblivion because my character is in no
way directly tied to the fate of the
world
i can be who i want to be and do what i
want to do
i don't have that save the world guilt
that i did in skyrim
the way i see it as long as you deliver
the amulet of kings to joffrey you can
walk away from the whole situation and
another nameless adventurer can step in
and take your place while you steal from
the rich or become the champion of the
arena
eventually you will become the
well-known hero but it's largely due to
your actions
and not your fate or destiny this not
only helps ground the player in the
world but it makes it all the more
satisfying when you do become the famous
hero of cyrodiil
believe me it was no picnic but thanks
to our friend here
i now know we can close these hell gates
now the world in oblivion is created for
the player as well
obviously but there are a lot of small
things in oblivion that feed into the
player's sense of insignificance in the
world a big one for
me is dungeon design oblivion's dungeons
are
baffling in 2021 by today's standards
and maybe even by 2006 standards many of
them
are pretty poorly designed they can be
meandering they typically don't have a
clear end point
sometimes there isn't even worthwhile
loot at the end and they rarely have a
shortcut that takes you back to the
entrance
on paper this is bad level design
there's really no getting around that
fact
but unlike skyrim the dungeons and caves
in oblivion
don't feel like dungeons that are made
specifically for the player to check off
a list
instead they feel like a cave goblins
might live in
or an abandoned fort that bandits might
hide out in they don't feel like they
exist simply to have a rare weapon at
the end with a convenient shortcut that
takes you
right back to the entrance i realize
this might be a huge turn off to some
but i think it really hammers home the
feeling of the player being a small part
of a larger world
to add to this bethesda put a lot of
work into oblivion's ai while it may not
sound like much now each and every npc
has a unique schedule they'd follow
unless the player interrupted them
characters would sleep at night work
during the day
and interact with other characters
throughout their lives it's janky by
today's standards but seeing and knowing
that any given npc had a routine to
carry out whether you're nearby
or not really gave the world a strong
sense of presence
what's most impressive is that you can
interact with every single character
not everyone has a lot to say but you
could stop them in the street and ask
them about local rumors which could
point you to different dungeons or
quests i say janky by today's standards
but in many ways it felt more ambitious
than skyrim
every npc serves a purpose in the world
even if there's no reason for you to
talk to them and even if their dialogue
is a bit dry
knowing that you can go up and talk to
anyone really sells the believability of
the world
no one feels like mere set dressing like
some of the non-indirectable characters
in skyrim
as a kid this is what really brought me
into that world i would spend
hours in one of the many towns just
taking in the sights meeting all the
residents and observing their day-to-day
lives
it's a bit rudimentary but it's
interesting seeing how bethesda's design
shifted because of npc schedules most
notably this lend itself to the dark
brotherhood quest line which sometimes
requires you to do reconnaissance before
carrying out a murder
hey come on stop right there
nobody breaks the law on my watch what
now pay your fine or it's off to jail
what this broader theme of
insignificance also gives the player a
good reason to tackle side quests join
guilds and explore the world at their
own pace
this is especially important for a
series like the elder scrolls if i can
be whoever i want and do whatever i want
i'd rather not be the chosen one
especially when the best parts of
oblivion are its side quests and guilds
[Music]
if you take anything away from this
video then let it be this
the biggest reason to give oblivion a
crack in 2021
are its side quests talk to dirham in
the inn
i'm tired of this minstrels freak show
our town has turned into
i'm not going to beat around the bush
here oblivion side quests are fantastic
sure there are some stinkers there like
getting this argonian or potatoes back
but some are so
wonderfully creative and imaginative
that it's easy to forgive the bad
there's one called paranoia where an elf
named garther approaches you as soon as
you arrive in one of the major cities
we can't talk here to public meet me
behind the
great chapel at midnight don't let
anyone follow you
i'll make it worth your while when you
meet him he asks you to follow a few
townsfolk he thinks are spying on him
you can either follow through on his
plan or turn him into the guards at any
step
along the way what you do and what info
you give him affects the trajectory of
the quest
and how much gold you can squeeze out of
them a major part of paranoia is
following around npcs to see if they are
doing anything suspicious
spoilers they aren't but it's a
brilliant little introduction to npc
schedules
as a kid i meticulously followed every
single person on glarthier's list
just to see how the world operated
there's another wonderful little quest
called where the spirits have leased
that is more or less a haunted house
story nestled right into oblivion
there's an intriguing setup and a
worthwhile twist
full disclosure this quest terrified me
as a kid but i always pushed through it
because i knew the reward was always
worth the trouble
we can't forget the quest simply titled
shea gorath either which lets you team
up with the daedric prince of madness to
trick
an entire village into thinking the
world is ending there's even a part
where flaming dogs fall from the sky
it's a must-see quest for sure or the
dark cloud over hector which
is basically a wicker man-like story in
the elder scrolls universe
don't push or luck stranger plenty of
folks have turned up dead after asking
questions like that
honestly even today i'm still impressed
by how absurd and creative some of these
side quests
are i could go on and on about them but
i also think it's worth mentioning the
guild quests in oblivion particularly
the dark brotherhood this guild
questline will send you to all corners
of the map murdering people in clever
ways
one highlight is the side quest called
whodunit which is basically a murder
mystery where you are the murderer at a
house party you could just murder all
the guests outright but that wouldn't be
as fun now would it
going back to what i said before i think
the reason why i remember oblivion so
fondly is that everything feels a bit
off some of it's intentional like the
twisted undercurrent to many of the side
quests while some of it
isn't like the character models and the
poor dungeon design but i think even
today those disparate and varied parts
paint a picture of an ambitious game
filled to the seams with new and
interesting ideas that bethesda never
really explored again
underneath that conventional fantasy
setting is an experience that
always keeps you guessing sometimes it's
moments like is this excursion into a
cave going to be worthwhile
while other times you might find
yourself stranded out at sea because you
rented a room in the wrong hotel
don't get me wrong skyrim has moments
like this too but oblivion surprised me
in ways skyrim never managed to
maybe it's because todd yes i was in the
chess club howard and the team at
bethesda
were still experimenting with their
flagship rpg series or maybe the team
itself looked
very different back then but oblivion
just had an ambitious innocence to it
that led to some
wonderfully memorable moments in a
seemingly familiar
world sure a lot of my passion for
oblivion is fueled by an ambiguous
intangible sense of nostalgia like
stepping out of the prison sewers for
the first time or hearing the music
swell as you explore the green hills of
the heartlands or your first encounter
with a dark brotherhood but i think
even today it's worth giving oblivion a
shot for the many stories it holds
and because it will probably be another
half decade before we hear more about
the elder scrolls 6.
anyway what are some of your favorite
memories in oblivion let me know in the
comments below
and as always thank you so much for
watching
by azura by azura by astoria it's the
grand
champion i can't believe it's you
standing
here next to me
[Music]
you